several people were injured and at least  one person was arrested during a  demonstration by white nationalists at  the University of Virginia in  Charlottesville last night hundreds of  marchers carried torches and chanted  before fights broke out near a statue of  Thomas Jefferson they were protesting  the planned removal of a Confederate  monument from a city park police used  pepper spray to control the crowd nearly  a thousand officers will be on hand for  today's unite the right rally which is  expected to draw thousands of white  nationalist neo-nazis and far-right  political groups along with counter  protesters